hi this is presh talwalkar in this video
i'm going to explain the formula for
wind chill
let's take a look at the current weather
conditions in new york city
now the current conditions actually
refer to a lot of different variables
but when people want to know what the
weather is like they usually want to
know what the air temperature is
in this case 20 degrees
but when it gets colder people are
usually more interested in the wind
chill because that tells you what the
temperature feels like so what does it
mean that the temperature feels like
it's 13 degrees
the temperature refers to the air
temperature and that's usually good
measure of what it feels like outside
but when there's a lot of wind that wind
is going to remove heat from your body
and objects and that'll make the objects
cool faster
so scientists have actually measured the
effect that wind has on cooling objects
in some of the original studies they
looked at how quickly water in a plastic
bottle would cool when there's a lot of
wind
they summarize the results in a wind
chill formula
so this is a formula that takes the
temperature and fahrenheit
and the wind speed in miles per hour and
converts it to an equivalent temperature
of how much that wind is going to reduce
the temperature so the formula is 35.74
plus
0.6215 times the temperature
plus
v raised to the power of 0.16 times the
quantity
0.4275 times t
minus 35.75
so we're going to explain what this
formula means so imagine at first
there's very little wind the wind speed
is one
so basically that term of v to the 0.16
will vanish
and when you collect the terms you end
up with the wind chill is equal to the
temperature minus 0.01
so what that means is when there's no
wind the wind basically has no effect so
the wind chill it's going to feel like
what the air temperature is
however when there is a lot of wind this
v to the power of 0.16 is going to have
an effect so let's look at what happens
when the temperature is 20 we'll
substitute 20 for t equals 20
and we'll look at the other variable of
wind speed
here we have a wind speed of 5 miles per
hour so we're going to take that
term of v and we're going to set v equal
to 5.
so now we have an equation expression
for the windchill
and when we evaluate it we get 12.98
so we calculated the wind chill was
12.98 and this pretty much exactly
matches the wind chill of 13 degrees
so that's where the windchill formula
comes from
and you can use it to evaluate the wind
chill when you know the temperature and
the wind speed
i hope you like this video please
subscribe to my channel
you can support me on patreon for
exclusive rewards catch me on my blog
mindyourdecisions on twitter at
preshtalwalker and you can get my books
listed on my website